adele gets candid about her weight loss
specifically how she lost 100 pounds and
the public's reaction to it
the grammy winner shocked fans back in
2020 when she posted this pic to
instagram on her 32nd birthday rocking a
little black dress the pic gained more
than 12 million likes and almost a
quarter million comments mostly about
her physique it looks really amazing now
the hello singer is opening up about
losing 100 pounds in both the british
and american issues of vogue telling the
mag that she lost the weight over the
course of two years and she started
working out to curb her anxiety quote it
was never about losing weight it was
always about becoming stronger and
giving myself as much time every day
without my phone i got quite addicted to
it i work out two or three times a day
absolutely yeah adele's routine she'll
lift weights in the morning hike or box
in the afternoon and do cardio at night
but she insists she isn't and never has
been on a diet quote if anything i eat
more than i used to because i work out
so hard i feel amazing about it adele
says people were shocked she didn't
share her weight loss journey along the
way or try to get sponsorship deals out
of it she reacts quite bluntly telling
the mag i couldn't give a flying i did
it for myself and not anyone else so why
would i ever share it i don't find it
fascinating it's my body but the public
was fascinated with adele's weight loss
and adele admits that a lot of the
chatter was hurtful i don't even know
why to be honest i don't get it quote i
understand why it's a shock i understand
why some women especially were hurt
visually i represented a lot of women
but i'm still the same person and the
worst part of the whole thing was that
the most brutal conversations were being
had by other women about my body i was
very disappointed with that that hurt my
feelings but adele wants her fans to
know this body positivity comes in all
shapes and sizes
quote you don't need to be overweight to
be body positive you can be any shape or
size knowing adele all that conviction
will be channeled into her new music
earlier this week she dropped a teaser
for her latest single easy on me
the british singer tells the mag it's
sensitive for me this record justin how
much i love it i always say that 21
doesn't belong to me anymore everyone
else took it into their hearts so much
i'm not letting go of this one this is
my album i want to share myself with
everyone but i don't think i'll ever let
this one go